[Music]
christina is with us in phoenix arizona
hi christina how are you
i'm good thank you how are you better
than i deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call um i was
wondering about
selling our home um in this great market
right now
so we purchased the home for about 160
we owe about 110 still
and it's listing for about 450.
um the thing is that we have significant
student loans
um we have about 275 worth of student
loans 275
000. 000 for what who's the doctor or
lawyer
my husband is a physician's assistant
and i'm a mental health therapist
good okay so your household income over
200
um it should be this year um this year i
really hit it hard with my own
my own private practice good good and
what was it last year
um about 165 yeah
okay and so you got a pretty good
trajectory on both of your careers
which is the payoff for getting good
degrees but now we've got the uh the
debt associated with them right
yeah yeah well it sounds like you've got
a choice
mathematically you've got a choice live
like a college student
spend absolutely no money and keep your
house
and be debt-free in three years
or sell your house
my husband wants to keep it for like a
rental type of no
you don't need a rental you're broke
you're 275 thousand dollars in debt
you're not in a position to be investing
in real estate
well not right now i know we pay
everything off i know okay
okay so do you want to live there with
absolutely no
work like absolute maniacs and clean up
this
ridiculous mess that you have in three
years
or less or do you want to sell the house
to get out now
either one is okay there's no bad answer
here
it's what you want to do
i would love to sell i'm i'm eager to
get out of debt
he likes the idea or he's playing around
with the idea of selling it but
um he's definitely more for the he wants
it for that potential
passive type of income later on no
um well that's that's that's long-term
thinking which is not bad
but i don't know if he realizes what
this is about to cost him he's not going
out to eat for the next three years
he's not going on vacation for the next
three years two kids
yeah it's hard yeah can kiddos survive
without restaurants they have done it
for centuries yeah they don't even
give them a bowl of of goldfish and
chicken nuggets and they're thrilled so
this isn't about the kids
i think dave brings up a good point does
he understand no
how hard this is going to be to pay this
off in three years i don't think he does
well no i mean he's yeah he's really
good with money so he's attacking
no he's not he's 275 000 in debt he's
not good with money
i mean he attacked it really hard during
this uh no interest
i mean he went down from 170 to about
140
so he's he's definitely working hard at
that
i i just think that if you're the one
that wants to pay the house off now
you've got to cast a little bit more
vision for him
that's the one i would choose but i
would sit down with stacy and go here's
why i want this if we sell this now
boom it's done we both make really good
income
we can rent in a really nice place and
still be
emergency fund fully funded immediately
with the kind of income you guys have
and we could save up and then we can get
a nicer house and put a really great
down payment on it
i just think you got to show him the
other side of this as opposed to what i
think is a status symbol which is this
i'd like to have passive income with
this small house
i would just cast different vision here
have you guys really talked about
your side of this thing and where it
fast forwards your life
so much faster
have you done that i have yes i have
honed in on that like this week that's
why
you know i've been trying to call all
week no i'm saying
you've talked about that and painted a
clear vision for how this fast forwards
everything
i i believe i have yes okay so here
here's what i heard
i just told you to pay off a hundred
thousand dollars a year and you went and
bragged about him paying off 30
000 in one year
well in a couple months oh a couple
months she did that
you said during the no interest and the
no interest has been a year
so that's why i'm sorry um oh yeah i
mean it's probably since
i guess about a year or since the
beginning of the year or so
the beginning of the year he's hit it
hard yeah he hit it hard
okay because a hundred thousand dollars
a year is eight thousand dollars a month
so thirty thousand would be done in just
a little over three months
if he did that then he's hitting it hard
i'll go with you okay
but i heard it i heard a year i thought
i heard a year when you said that you
didn't say a year but i heard
since they stopped having interest on
the loans which has been a year so
anyway
okay so yeah and by the way he was
paying off his debt
not our debt so somehow i don't know
where we got on that but
i think the two of you need to sit down
together and go all right
one of these two things is going to
happen we're either going to have no
lifestyle
and we're going to hit this hard for
three years and be debt free
300 000 in three years or we're going to
sell the house
rent for a little while have an
emergency fund build up cash
for a down payment and buy another house
and we'll buy rentals later
you're always going to have good incomes
because you have two very good career
fields if you work hard and
you know continue with your craft and so
on right so you know
a 200 250 000 income it's not hard to
save up and
pay off your own home and then save up
and buy your first rental
within the first decade here it's very
doable but
but but i think you're getting the cart
in front of the horse he is he's
starting we're talking about rental
properties
while we still have a house mortgage and
we still have 275 000
of student loan debt it's out of order
that comes
later so i i would either sell the house
or hold on to it with the idea that
we're probably going to sell it later
and move up in-house and get that house
paid off before we start adding rentals
paying it off and paying off the student
loan debt and then going and taking a
mortgage to buy your next home
is not something i would tell you to do
and so he's again
putting the cart before the horse with
all that so i'm kicking this rental
thing down the road a little bit i like
rental property i want you to have some
rental property
but um you don't broke people shouldn't
buy rental property
it's not a good thing makes you broker
that's why i call them real estate
brokers